do you believe that we're dealing with  multiple phenomenon that have different  explanations rather than a single one  yeah  definitely  so why do you think that  because they look very different so orbs  look different than tic tacs which  i don't even know if they are  extraterrestrial um and there are things  that like i could see from catholic  history from like you know 1400 1500  that look like john max abductions you  know and you can say wow that looks  exactly like you know it could become it  could come out of john mack's book  uh  i think it's called abduction actually  um human encounters with aliens  so yeah those are different i mean i  think they're different i could be wrong  but they look different